ich war gerade joggen und während ich so
lief sah ich einen
Aldi und da habe ich mich an viele
Kommentare erinnert die gesagt haben bei
vielen Kalendern da nehmen Sie doch
lieber den 1 € al die Kalender geil und
ganz ehrlich wenn das so oft gesagt wird
dann muss da doch auch was dran sein
oder sie hatten aber leider nicht mehr
diese Motive aus meiner Kindheit die so
richtig schön weihnachtlich waren so
richtig richtig so eine winter
wonderland der Weihnachtsmann kommt um
die Ecke Landschaft jetzt haben die halt
Pepper pig Minions und paw Patrol und
der Kalender kostet nicht 1 € sondern
1,1 Cent nicht mal 1 Euro konnte damals
meine Mutter für mich ausgeben ich hätte
so oft kein Adventskalender zum 1
dezember ist wahrscheinlich auch der
Grund warum ich jetzt 300 pro Jahr
auspacke und bevor ich jetzt noch zu oft
Aldi sage oder Pepper pig dieses Video
ist definitiv nicht gesponser und jetzt
alle dieses Videos definitiv nicht
gesponser eine letzte Maßnahme bevor es
losgeht
und Jetzt Geht's
[Musik]
Ab das ist tatsächlich Freitagabend und
wir waren schon Joggen ich geh jetzt zu
den Leuten die in ihren die alt geworden
sind und auf ihren Körper achten müssen
und nicht jedes Wochenende Feier gehen
können ich kann es gar nicht glauben
dass ich das sag mein
Auge seht ihr das mein Auge zckt schon
den ganzen Tag ich habe eine Reise für
Dezember geplant von 11 bis 17 Uhr Züge
gebucht Hotels gebucht eine krasse Reise
machen dieses Jahr hoffentlich wieder
vlogm immer wenn ich an diese Reise
denke und an dieses buchen und so fängt
mein Auge wieder an zu zucken ich glaube
das hat mich so
gestressst aber ich freue mich so drauf
ihr wir gar nicht glauben vlogm dieses
Jahr falls ihr mich und meinen Kanal
noch nicht so gut kennt jedes Jahr
versuche ich vlogmas zu machen vlogmas
ist bzw bedeutet dass man jeden Tag im
Dezember bis Weihnachten einen Vlog
hochlädt und sonst habe ich das immer
versucht alleine zu machen letztes Jahr
hat mir TE schon ein bisschen geholfen
und dieses Jahr hilft er mir komplett
das heißt es könnte sowas werden und ich
möchte auch dass diese vlogmas Zeit
richtig cool und spannend wird und so
deswegen habe ich mir ein bisschen auch
was überlegt und ja das darüber habe ich
mich heute gekümmert und das alter
Schwede
das so wir machen das hier wie bei jedem
anderen Kalender auch optisch
wunderschön weihnachtlich sehr simpel
gehaltenes Design sehr leichter Kalender
also wirklich das ist wahrscheinlich der
leichteste den ich jetzt bis jetzt hatte
und wir starten mit Türchen Nummer
ein ich fühle mich wirklich
zurückversetzt das ist der og
Adventskalender genau so muss es sein
bin so gespannt was für Motive jetzt da
drin
sind das ist er das ist er ich sag euch
ehrlich ich hatte ein bisschen Angst
dass da Peppa pig Motive drin sein
werden aber nein das ist doch was man
haben möchte wenn euch das nicht in eure
Kindheit zurückversetzt und jetzt testen
wir ich flipp doch aus ich habe das
Gefühl mein Körper hat so muscle memory
ich weiß ganz genau wie es schmecken
sollte wie es sich anfühlen sollte und
alles stimmt perfekt wir richtig
emotional das Gefühl jetzt auch ich
schmecke wie ich mich jetzt anziehen
muss meine Zähne putzen muss und zur
Schule gehen muss ich werde gerade so
unnötig emotional tüchen Nummer 2 und
heute gibt's ein
Teddybär okay gut das war wohl ein Tick
zu viel fällt mir so eine traurige
Geschichte ein also unsere Eltern war
wirklich nie gut darin uns
Adventskalender zu schenken also
wirklich katastrophal waren sie wir
machen ja immer so Scherze also Kelly
und Mirella damals auch und ich haben ja
immer so diese Scherze gemacht so aha
unsere Ausländer Eltern aber es gibt
echt so ein paar Sachen aus meiner
Kindheit wo ich sag das wäre echt
irgendwie schön gewesen wenn es ein
bisschen anders gewesen wäre und mir
fällt gerade eine Story ein von meiner
Schwester die hat in der Schule so getan
hat sie mir mal erzählt dass wir über
Adventskalender geredet haben sie hat in
der Schule sich Motive überlegt die in
ihrem Adventskalender drin waren weil
wir hatten ja kaum welche oder
vielleicht viel zu spät oder na ja wir
hatten halt nicht welche und dann wenn
morgens in der Schule jeder gesagt hat
oh was war deinem ja bei mir war ein
Teddybär bei mir war eine Glocke bei mir
war das hat sich Motiv aus gedacht h ein
bisschen anders
ne Türchen Nummer 3 wie flipt do raus
heute gibt's einen Stern wie Schokolade
istam 75 g easy mit jedem Bissen wird
die Schokolade auch besser auchen
Klassiker der Zug versuche mal den
Geschmack zu
beschreiben Zucker Kakaobutter
magerilchpulver Alter das süßmenpulver
drin so viel Laktose wir braten wir
jetzt was in Türchen Nummer 5 drin ist
eine Glocke da kommt seit hautnah mit
dabei jemand der auf dem Schlitten fährt
was mich aber extrem triggert das ist
halt für alle gleich gemacht ne aber
dass das hier halt immer ein Pepper pick
ist das ist nicht das gleiche Motiv drin
ist Nikolaus an Nikolaus ist das Haus
von Nikolaus
drin alles gleich ne ich habe mir das
schon genauso gedacht diese Idee ist so
für 5 Minuten lustig
ich möchte wieder in diese Zeit zurück
wo das die aufregendsten Motive sind auf
die man sich freut wo es nicht die ganze
Zeit Handys gibt wo man sich so
überlegen muss wie man sich am
Nachmittag beschäftigt mid crisis 30
werden steht mir nicht so gut ich bin
ich bin noch nicht bereit erwachsen zu
sein ziehen wir das wir ziehen das jetzt
durch ne vielleicht seid ihr auch ein
bisschen nostalgisch mit mir zusammen
denkt euch bei den Motiven oh stimmt ich
erinnere mich
dran jetzt kommt Türchen Nummer ne und
Türchen Nummer ne ist das beste Türchen
weil es meine Lieblingszahl ist Mensch
was macht denn der Nikolaus hier ist ein
Zwerg Nummer ze ein
Horn dafür war ich gerade Joggen in
Nummer 11 ist mein absolutes
Lieblingsmotiv auch schon früher gewesen
die Sternschnuppe für mich ein absoluter
Klassiker bei den Weihnachtsmotiven wenn
ich Weihnachtskarten früher gebastelt
habe ich habe immer Sternschnuppen drauf
gebastelt aber sind sternchumen sind die
so weihnachtlich bei keksausstechern da
gibt's auch immer sternschumen aber
warum ist das so ein weihnachtliches
Motiv
Halbzeit Nummer 12 auch toll das
Geschenk ein
Schlitten ich habe e brauch ein bisschen
Pause hab einfach nicht geschafft ein
richtiges Video zu drehen für diesen
Sonntag Leute mein Auge hat heute
angefangen zu zcken bin kurz
vormerv meine Managerin meinte schon zu
mir und auch okay wenn kein Video kommt
find ich nicht und jetzt gucken wir was
in Türchen Nummer 14 drin ist das ist
aber auch immer das beste Gefühl dieses
Ding so rauszukloppen ne hübsches tolles
Motiv ganz
kurz die Pfanne von hast du die
wegesmissen habe ich zu den anderen
Pfannen gepackt was hast du mit den
Pfannen
gemacht vor die Tür
gestellt dabei oder was
nicht dein
[Musik]
Ernst 15 meine Glocke da ist sie da ist
da ist meine
Glocke 16
Kreise sind immer vielversprechend
Flugzeug ist ein Flugzeug ein
weihnachtliches
Motiv komm Leute wir ziehen das jetzt
gemeinsam durch ihr habt euch dieses
Video angefangen anzuschauen jetzt denkt
ihr euch wahrscheinlich auch an dem
Punkt so was mache ich hier eigentlich
gerade wir entspannen uns das Leben ist
anstrengend wir haben Stress unser Auge
fängt an zu zucken und da brauchen wir
Vanessa die einfach mal banal ein
Adventskalender für 1 €o auspackt Nummer
17 Pepper pig Pepper pig hilft uns dabei
unseren Stress zu
vergessen sehr
langweilig
18 das ist genau die Zeit als ich noch
da gab es noch extra und nicht Rewe
könnt euch noch an extra erinnern da war
immer Nikolaus der Nikolaus da und man
konnte mit seinem Schuh oder mit seiner
hinkommen und dann wurde das da
reingefüllt das ist meine schönste
winterliche
weihnachtserinnerung 19 da erzähl ich
euch die Geschichte wie mir was in Schuh
gepackt wurde und jetzt ist ein Schuh
drin das kommt von ganz oben ich bin auf
dem richtigen fahr
20 die fallen aber auch schon raus ich
glaub dass ich früher mit meinen kleinen
Patsche Kinderhänden da ein bisschen
mehr rumkrabbeln
musste Windel Candy was tue ich hier
gerade ich bin wirklichade vom jogen
gekommen jetzt fter ich hier Schokolade
in Türchen Nummer
21 gibt es ein Auto
toll ich kann es ir gerade selber nicht
glauben bitte leute wenn ihr bis hier
noch dran geblieben seid liked und
kommentiert dieses Video ich möchte dass
es gepusht wird ich möchte dass dieses
Video über einen 1 € Aldi
Adventskalender 500.000 views bekommt
und jeder der dann so da drauf stößt
soll ich einfach nur denken what the
[__] also die die es nicht checken ihr
die die
soll einfach nur drauf klicken und den
die packt da ganz serious diesen
Kalender aus meine Auge zuckt schon
wieder wenn ihr wisst warum ein Auge
anfängt so zu zucken dann schreibt in
die Kommentare falls Ihr Kommentar
braucht 22 ein Mann der sehr creepy ein
Pferd
umarmt komische Pole unser vorletztes
Türchen aus unserem pepperpig al die 1€
Adventskalender oh mein Gott oh mein
Gott was ist
es da hast du gleich als Kind ein Trauma
kpelle sehr creepy Türchen 24 es ist
Weihnachten das war wirklich ein toller
Adventskalender der war günstig er war
lecker er hat uns jeden Morgen so ein
kleinen zuckerpush gegeben und jetzt
gehen wir an das 24 Türchen was ein
doppeltürchen ist das erste
doppeltürchen wir machen auf und
dahinter die Mutter der
adventskalendermtive der Engel denn
heute Nacht kommt Engel
der wird mich an schreien und fragen ob
ich dumm bin dass ich so viel feigpulver
gegessen habe bist du kaputt in dein
Kopf aber okay
so kommen wir nun zu einem Fazit ich
muss mal kurz überlegen was so drin war
die Schokolade hat mir ganz gut gefallen
die Schokolade auch und die Schokolade
fand ich auch gar nicht schlecht also so
alles zusammen ein toller Kalender die
Motive ich bin so froh dass sie die
Motive nicht verändert haben ohne Witz
wir brauchen gerade in so schlimmen Zeit
wir heute irgendwas was uns ein bisschen
ein Gefühl von einer geborgenen schönen
Kindheit irgendwie gibt und wenn es dann
so ein Motiv von einem 1 €
schokoladenadventskalender ist dann ist
es doch auch okay und schön und Petition
an Aldi ja ihr könnt eure Pepper pigs
und Minions und sowas drauf machen aber
verkauft auch noch ein paar mit einem
weihnachtlichen Motiv und macht den
vielleicht vegan oder laktosefrei
wenigstens das wäre toll und ansonsten
würde ich sagen ich kann den Kalender
empfehlen also Leistung stimmt hier
wirklich und ja wir sehen uns dann beim
nächsten Video wieder bis dann tschüssi